[Music]
what's up guys I'm gonna be showing you
a good canon guide on how to get some
range XP and make some profit while
doing it so just have your best range
gear that you can have
that's not relatively expensive and then
I'm gonna use it on our boats cuz
they're not that expensive and then have
your Canon have some food in case the
peak here comes the reason why I
probably have a little bit too much for
just cuz I just got peak aid there and I
had forgotten to bring my food so I got
killed so make sure to bring your food
don't be an idiot like me and then bring
a looting bag bring about a hundred or
so canons a ranging pot and a stamina
potion additionally you want to have a
teleport out of there so I just have a
rig over doing to get out there and so
go ahead and sip some of your stamina
potion and then go ahead and run out
here when I go to the green drags that
are up this way
like I said there are P cares so just
pay attention and you won't die it's not
too hard to run away so make sure to
have an anti Dragon shield
so no one's here so go ahead and run in
the middle of the Dragons so that we can
in and let it fire it if you don't want
to get hit by the Dragons you can rise
just run up here and they can't hit you
but what I like to do I like to kind of
say spot them and just get some HP so if
you tag them then just run away can't
get to you all right I'll be back when I
use 500 cannonballs so when you're
running low on cannonballs just go ahead
and tell you out and leave your kin in
there and I'll keep getting kills and
then come back what's up guys i just got
done took me about 35 minutes and I did
get peak aid and lost a full inventory
so I'll add that into consideration at
the end yeah like I said don't afk
because I have Kaede for about 2 seconds
and then died I'm so about 330k and also
a clue scroll and then plus another
inventory so another inventory would be
like let's just do get rid of 19 of
these and 19 of these we'll just we'll
just we'll just like kind of estimate so
330k plus under 54 so 330 plus 151 so
480 K okay so so 480 K minus the 96 k
equals 385 so we'll just times the by 2
because it took about 30 minutes to do
that so let's watch 700 Evan k and if
you do it at max efficiency it'll be at
least 800 K so about 800 K an hour so
thanks for watching guys just an FYI I
won't be making a video for a while I'm
going back to college now so if I have
time to make them during my break so
I'll make them but if not I'll probably
see you guys in the summer so thanks for
watching guys and hopefully you guys
stay with me and just wait to like them
back